Hi quick thinkers and slowpokes, it’s Julian
for DNews.
Tim Welsh, a professor of Kinesiology at the
University of Toronto recently wrote an article
asking, “what is the speed of thought?”
It’s a great question with a lot of different
answers because thoughts can be huge complex
puzzles or simple reflexes.
They can originate internally or from external
stimuli, and different people can have the
same thought at different speeds.
We thought we’d offer our own answer and
to give us somewhere to start, let’s talk
about the basic unit of a thought.
A thought can be billions of neurons interacting
with each other at once, swapping chemicals
between them to communicate.
So it could be said the most basic unit of
thought is a neuron firing.
Neurons in your brain consist of cell bodies
with dendrites branching from it, as well
as an axon that splits several times at the
end.
People know that neurons send electrical impulses
but it’s not like the electricity in your
house that works by passing freely moving
electrons, so it’s not as instantaneous.
Instead neurons swap ions of different charges
across the membrane of the axon.
By swapping them at the start of the axon
by the cell body, it starts a chain reaction
down its length, like a row of people doing
the wave.
When the signal gets to the end of the axon,
the synaptic bundle will release neurotransmitters
across the synaptic cleft, which is the tiny
space between the end of one neuron and the
beginning of the next.
The neurotransmitters float to the next neuron’s
dendrites, and they tell the next neuron how
to fire.
So the total time it takes a cell to send
an impulse down its axon and then diffuse
a neurotransmitter across the synapse is our
most basic unit, and of course, this being
the brain we’re talking about, it gets even
more complicated.
Because axons can either belong to gray matter
or white matter.
40% of your brain’s volume is gray matter,
it’s what you use for sensory perception,
speech, memory, emotions, and decision making.
It’s dense with cell bodies and the axons
are short and don’t have a fatty protein
called myelin surrounding them.
White matter on the other hand doesn’t do
the thought processing but is vital for connecting
different areas of gray matter because it
has that myelin sheath.
That sheath is like the difference between
a fiber optic cable and a 56k modem.
Without it, grey matter sends its electrical
pulses at .5 to 10 meters per second.
With it, white matter’s action potential
can travel up to 150 meters per second.
It needs that speed, because white matter
axons in a man in his 20s can total over 176,000
kilometers.
The axons in white matter can be up to a meter
long, which is good because that means fewer
synapses slowing the signal down.
A synapse is a gap between neurons of only
20 nanometers.
Some transmissions across the synapse can
be quick; if the neurotransmitter opens up
the ion channels right away, the whole process
can take just half a millisecond.
Most receptors however use the neurotransmitter
to release another molecule and that secondary
messenger opens up the ion channels.
That can delay the signal anywhere from 30
milliseconds to a full second.
So between axon length, axon type, and neurotransmitter
used, there’s a lot of variability in the
speed an individual neuron can send a message.
Now consider that a single neuron can have
links with thousands of other neurons, meaning
your brain can have hundreds of trillions
of synapses between its 86 billion neurons.
Plus there are different kinds of thought,
like reflexes fast tracked to the spinal cord
or complex decisions that use billions of
neurons across your brain.
All of these variables mean thoughts can be
had and carried out at vastly different speeds.
It’s why some thoughts can be nearly instantaneous,
like a sprinter starting to move only 150
milliseconds after a starter’s pistol; while
others take much longer, like deciding whether
or not you should tell your crush how you
feel.
It is possible to think faster though.
Reactions can become reflexes with practice,
taking neurons and distance a signal has to
travel out of the equation to speed a thought
up.
Or complex decisions can be made quicker with
practice too.
Making different parts of your brain communicate
by learning and considering new information
can improve the structural integrity of the
white matter used, letting it send signals
faster, making you better at processing information.
It’s another great reason to keep coming
back for more DNews.
I know, shameless plug.
You probably have about 86 billion neurons
rolling around up there, and you may think
you only use 10% of them.
You don’t.
I hate that factoid and Anthony Carboni agrees.
Here’s the video
with the truth.
What are your thoughts on thoughts?
Are you quick at learning and thinking or
do you need more practice?
Let us know in the comments or facebook or
twitter, subscribe for more brain food, and
I’ll see you next time on DNews.